[Music]
the day was march 18th 2010. an apple
engineer goes out to the bar on his
birthday with an unreleased iphone 4
in his pocket three months before we're
supposed to come out now this isn't
actually unusual you know in the final
months leading up to a launch they've
got to do their testing and finalizing
things in the real world sometimes to
iron out any bugs and find any last
second fixes so he's probably using it
maybe even as a daily but it's in a case
that actually disguises it as an iphone
3gs
now unfortunately maybe too many drinks
maybe a bit distracted on his birthday
he forgets that phone at the bar
and leaves without it from there
somebody else picks it up realizes it's
a top secret unreleased iphone 4 not a
3gs so that person tries to return it to
apple who actually refuses it because
the customer service rep doesn't believe
that anyone would have an iphone 4 to
return must be a knockoff or something
from there that person realizes what
they have so they go to sell this
unreleased iphone to try to get some
money for it and it's bought
by gizmodo
at this point apple's realized the phone
is missing they remotely wiped it but
gizmodo goes on to publish a hands-on
which as you can imagine went absolutely
nuts because not only is this an
unreleased iphone in the flesh
but it's also now stolen property so
gizmodo details all the new features and
takes tons of pictures tears it apart
compares it to old iphones and basically
details everything apple's been working
on three months before apple is planning
on showing it themselves now apple
meanwhile is trying everything in their
power to get this phone back they send
letters from lawyers steve jobs calls
the gizmodo executive editor and
eventually a few days later california
police raid gizmodo editor jason chen's
home and sees four computers two servers
three hard drives and other gadgets
while he was out to dinner they broke
down his front door so the iphone 4 was
eventually unveiled on stage like three
months later in june and that was kind
of the end of that messy story but the
point is that was one of the biggest
tech leaks
of all time it had everything it had
stolen property it had tear downs it had
pre-released top secret hardware all
that but the thing that really made it
such a big leak wasn't just the fact
that we got this aesthetic stuff early
it was really the the industry secret
they tore down the phone they showed
unreleased parts inside the phone to the
entire world including apple's
competitors and that's the type of leaks
that really hurt companies like apple
the most
and a lot of the serious leaks we see
nowadays are like supply chain related
they'll be such a big company but
there's no way they can lock down every
single little bit of their supply chain
and that's where little squeaks of leaks
will get out like just a couple months
ago we heard about hackers targeting not
apple but one of their suppliers and
claiming to have stolen blueprints of
future apple products that they would
publish unless they got 50 million
dollars of ransom but the thing is
leak culture if you want to call it that
has evolved a lot like there's of course
lots of that serious stuff still going
on and lots of reporting on that serious
stuff
but also leaks have sort of turned into
this
uh
version of casual entertainment as well
to the point where the iphone 14
was trending on twitter last week
before
we even have seen the iphone 13. so yeah
i figured this would be the perfect time
to share my thoughts on leaks and leak
culture so my personal philosophy the
way i've seen leaks in tech over the
years there's kind of two types of leaks
one
the serious type that we've illustrated
with the first example and those that
get reported a lot with industry secrets
and competitive advantage at stake
and the other
is uh
more casual
not super important mostly aesthetic and
generally for entertainment and i pay
attention of course to the first type of
leak but that second type
is usually not always worth paying a
whole lot of attention to or at least
expending a lot of energy keeping up
with like for example today on the
internet you can there's plenty of
places you can go to just follow leaks
for entertainment there are youtube
channels you can subscribe to there's
people you can follow on twitter for
constant leaks where that's all they do
there's even sites dedicated to it and
then also sort of accompanying it
there's also a whole genre of artists
who will make incredible cg renders of
gadgets based on the leaks to help us
visualize what the future gadgets could
look like but some of these leaks like i
said
not really worth paying a whole lot of
attention to i would say
like an example i think there was a john
prosser leak probably a couple months
ago where i think he confirmed
he leaked the exact
date and time
that a product announcement would happen
or that an embargo would drop or
something like that and then hours later
it was right it was confirmed
and you know shout out to john much
props to him funny guy great channel
but i don't care i just don't care
that's the type of stuff that's like
purely for entertainment and has
almost no effect on people who aren't
following it hardcore and i just feel
like there's there's little
entertainment leaks like this all the
time confirming that a product isn't
cancelled or a leak confirming a
product's name or the leak of an
announcement date or stuff like that
leaks that are just confirming the
existence of products being developed so
of course you know naturally all those
little bits of information that leak out
can and will be turned into content
because that's what we do
but generally i think it's safe to
ignore or at least pay a passing
attention to a lot of that stuff but
most of the leaks now that you'll see
that are actually
really entertaining
are completely aesthetic
all visual just because the question of
how will the product look
turns out to be one of the most
important things that people wonder
about an upcoming future product now i
could talk i could talk for hours about
how there are companies out there who
definitely
intentionally leak products and or just
intentionally leak little things because
if you were a company who saw all this
hype being generated about products of
course you want to get in on it assert
some level of control over the narrative
and jump in and generate even more hype
for your own benefit so i get that you
also see the one pluses of the world
where their literal pre-launch strategy
before dropping a new flagship phone is
once every few days release a new little
nugget of information for the nerds you
know hey this is the processor we're
going to be using or this is how fast
the phone's going to charge confirmed or
hey this is how much ram the thing will
have it's kind of annoying but it's
actually very smart because people pay
attention to that thing people care
about each one of these things so the
slow
drip of information acts the same way
a leak would in that it generates hype
it gets people talking about it the
press keeps going but really at the end
of the day what most people want to see
when the product does finally get to the
announcement date what they want to see
unveiled is the design the features and
the price just to keep it simple and
since the price is like the last thing
to get finalized and probably the
hardest thing to leak and get right
we all focus on the aesthetics we just
want to know the design how it's going
to look what the choices were made in
that outside and so the iphone 14
trending on twitter was mostly from a
john prosser video on some claimed leaks
and some renders of that phone that's
still over a year away
all aesthetic like they claim the iphone
14 may look a lot like the iphone 4. you
know round volume buttons hole punch
camera cut out at the top too
full flat glass and chamfers with the
new antenna placement flat camera bump
on the back
still lightning port at the bottom like
this is a hundred percent aesthetics
this is just speculating on how the
thing will look and there's almost no
actual technical speculation about
features or anything like that mostly
because there's a whole year before the
thing's supposed to come out it's it's
probably not finalized anyway and
there's a whole year of hype to be
generated before anything can be proven
wrong so it's entertaining
fun speculation for sure that is
definitely entertainment value but i
think the real question at the end of
the day for you guys would be
do leaks
ruin
launch events does following the leaks
and the little bit of information that
comes out before the launch event ruin
the fun or the surprise of the actual
launch moment and my answer might not be
exactly what you're expecting it might
be a little bit cynical but
i do think
that leaks or following them takes a
little bit of the air out of that like
big surprise moment but
those announcements are just more of the
hype anyway like okay it turns out there
are many many people out there that
don't follow the leaks at all they don't
read any articles or watch any videos or
think about the new phone at all before
the announcement and so that
announcement event is a genuinely new
thing and a surprise to them
and that's that's almost like a sweet
level of innocence that i kind of miss a
little bit to be honest um but also
there's some of those people out there
that are probably buying like fresh
brand new iphone 12s right now as the
iphone 13 is about to come out so maybe
if you have a friend like that let them
know
just warn them maybe shouldn't make that
purchase right now but if you are one of
those people sure
the announcement event will be way more
fun for you because everything there
will be brand new and surprising and
shock and awe sweet
but just know
that that announcement event
isn't just a spec rollout that's a
presentation like it's a whole show it's
a high budget highly refined and planned
presentation designed to show off and
get you to want to buy the new product
that they've been working on that
they're finally unveiling now on the
other hand if you do follow every single
leak like a lot of us do
then it almost feels like the
announcement is a guaranteed letdown
because now you've been building this
hype up for much much longer behind the
scenes
and then the announcement happens and
it's either not what the leaks suggested
which is a bit of a letdown or it's
exactly what the leak suggested
which is a bit of a letdown because
there were no surprises
and so that's just setting yourself up
for disappointment so anyway i think my
point is it's
basically impossible to generate the
correct level of hype
it's probably going to be overhyped no
matter how much leak following or
announcement hype that happens it's just
it's just all a big show and it's fun
and it's entertaining but i think this
leaked culture is clearly here to stay
this entertainment it's a new dimension
of being able to follow what looks like
these companies duking it out and
fighting each other in front of us
which is sort of a rich new thing to
feel like you're a part of people pick
teams and they see leaks and they can
switch and it's just a it's just a new
fun little thing so yeah it's
entertainment definitely entertaining
but i think as long as we all know that
these leaks or this entertainment is is
just that it's just entertainment these
little bits of information are just to
feel like we have a little bit more
information and it's just kind of fun to
follow and that it also feeds into the
consumerism that it's all a part of
then that's fine have your fun have our
entertainment
i'll catch you on the other side though
when the product actually comes out
that's my side anyway thanks for
watching catch you in the next one
peace